student loans Oh opportunities to get
rid of them sound irresistible but guess
what
they're probably too good to be true
thankfully Illinois became the first US
state to file lawsuits against two
companies that target people buried in
student loans the companies allegedly
promised sketchy solutions to help
desperate people get rid of their Dec
bogus student debt relief is booming and
it's not hard to see why student loan
debt in America is 1.2 trillion dollars
and Counting and affects over 40 million
Americans 7 million people are in
default of their loans but what's
troubling is that student debt relief
looks a lot like the wave of predatory
mortgage lenders that preyed on
homeowners during the 2008 housing
crisis so how are these companies
cashing in on borrowers well for
starters they're convincing young fresh
graduates to pay large upfront fees as
much as twelve hundred dollars illegally
that settlement companies are also
charging people for services that the
government offers for free like simply
filling out repayment forms and these
businesses also claim special
connections with the government with
names like the Obama forgiveness program
but there is no such government program
for student debt in fact even if you
declare bankruptcy you still have to pay
back your student loans it was easier
for General Motors to go bankrupt get a
government bailout dumped debt and start
over than it is for the average
Americans to get rid of a student loan
so it's easy to see why so many people
are desperately looking for a magical
fix everyone wants the way out and some
will go to anyone for relief